rien j'ai commis un article où je me
situe les zones fanfan et réincarnation
on a sur certains aspects une évolution
notable et je suis certains aspects
aussi il ya une volonté n'est ce pas la
france à y rester même si la ans se
cache derrière au fait que ce sont les
pires africains qui souhaitent continuer
à solliciter sa sonde accompagnement
mais c'est assez mal perçue par un
certain nombre de l'économiste par
certain nombre de leaders politiques en
afrique
je vois la france qui continue à
garantir cette monnaie près de 60 ans
après son déploiement des pays dont la
réalité on devrait pouvoir penser que
c'est une une transition parce que le
cordon ne devrait pas aussi se couper
brutalement
il a fallu les évolutions qui sont
intervenus dans la zone franc sont
intervenus après après plusieurs
plusieurs années de négociations dont
moi je suis optimiste quant à
l'évolution future de la zone franc qui
devrait pouvoir disparaître de mon point
de vue pour laisser la place avec ou à
une monnaie commune dans la la cedeao et
qui va aussi fédérer peut-être depuis la
finance appuyez center qui sont en
retard par rapport aux pays de l'afrique
d'afrique de l'ouest